من الدوحه من قلب الحدث سالنا الجمهور من
الفائز باعتقادكم في مباراه الارجنتين
وفرنسا تتابعون نعود لكم بالنقاش
هذا العام من سيتوج بكاس العالم في كره
القدم
بس حاليا انا ارجنتين لازم يتواجد
الارجنتين اتوقع الارجنتين لان الحضور
الجماهيري للارجنتين رهيب جدا فقوبه
الارجنتين بجماهيرها
والدعم الموجود من جميع انحاء العالم من
الارجنتين وميسي مش هيضيعوا عليهم اللقب
فرنسا فرنسا
انت شايف حتى المغرب عنده جمهور قوي
لكن الرباعي هذا ذنب بلا اليمين اليسار
هذا سلاح نوويه
فرنسا
[موسيقى]
ابطال العالم الى 2018
الفريق الارجنتيني يمتلك الخبره ويمتلك
امهر لاعب وهو ميسي رغم انه تقدم في يعني
العمر لكنه مازال مسيطر على الكره
قوي يعني الارجنتين قويه وفرنسي قويه
وعندهم مواهب ولاعبين كثيرين يعني نقدر
نقول لعبه يعني ما نقدر نقول ارجنتين او
فرنسا يعني بس الاكثر الاكثر ارجنتين